the major part of the livestock market  in Europe consists out of pig meat veal  and beef with 150 million pigs and a  yearly production of about twenty two  million ton carcass weight the EU is the  world's second biggest producer of pig  meat after China the EU has a bovine  heard of around 87 million and a total  yearly production of about 7.5 million  tonnes of beef farmers are in the street  because the livestock sector and the pig  meat sector in particular are having a  difficult time we produce too much in  relation to what is either consumed or  exported to third countries experts are  badly affected by the prolongation of  the Russian ban on European agricultural  products by restrictions linked to fit a  sanitary problems african swine fever  for instance and internally it's true we  consume less pig meat because of  changing eating habits